this is a story so I
I would read some of the story and
you're going to think that I'm going a
certain direction with it yeah but but
I'm not I will surprise you slightly
uh Daily Mail police have pictured a
Texas man arrested after his crazed pit
bulls mauled an elderly man to death and
badly injured the victim's wife
Christian Alexander Moreno 31 was
charged with attack by dangerous dog
causing death and injury to an elderly
person both felonies according to a
press release by the San Antonio Police
Department he was pictured being perp
walked from his home after Friday's
horrific mulling which was captured on
video the victim has been named as 81
year old Ramon najeras attack heard
along the 2800 block of depla Street on
the city's west side where Harris and
his wife 74 were visiting friends when
they got out of their car the couple
were set upon by uh by the two American
Staffordshire Terriers who had escaped
their yard so this I guess that would be
this is a bully breed of dog
uh is a bully breed but not a pit bull
right I think
um neither victim has been named with
the surviving woman said to be receiving
critical care now
the San Antonio fire department they
arrived on the scene
and there's video there's so there's
there's video of the actual attack of
this elderly man being
I mean I hate to put it this way but
being eaten by these dogs and the video
is I I happen to see this video very
much not wanting to see it but it's one
of those things scrolling on social
media and boom it pops up and there it
is
um
so there's video of the attack and then
the video continues and we see the
police that the fire department show up
and they're kind of like fending off the
dog they have their their pickaxes and
they're fending off the dogs this goes
on for a while and the police show up
and then some animal uh you know uh the
the people that deal with animals
Animal Care Services came and they took
the dogs and then brought them somewhere
else and then they were we were told we
were assured humanely euthanized
that's already a sad statement about
society when nobody including the cops
when no one shows up and just shoots
these damn things
and even when the Animal Care Services
come oh we gotta make sure we humanely
euthanize
they just mauled an elderly man to death
he is dead on the sidewalk in the middle
of an American town uh like this is some
kind of third world country this is not
okay we are not a third world country
and so we should not have animal
mullings should not be a thing that you
have to worry about in a modern American
town
but you do
because people bring these dogs into the
into the neighborhood nobody shoots the
dogs even they they make sure like well
we're going to take the dogs and then
and then and then they were euthanized
just shot the police said just shoot
them shoot them right there on the spot
and no one comes out of the house with a
gun it just shoots the animals
um
but that's my point
so you know how I feel about pit bulls
and any any of the bully breeds of dogs
uh I think they should all be banned and
they shouldn't be allowed in
neighborhoods to me that's incredibly
obvious
so I'm not going to harp on that because
you know how I feel about it
what I was
the thing that I kind of focused on when
I saw the video is that there's a video
of it and I know that we're used to this
by now it's barely even we just take it
for granted anytime anything horrible
happens we see it on video and so we all
then also witness it
but this modeling I mean it goes on for
a while and this elderly man it's I I
cannot think of a worse way to die
and and he is mulled to death by these
dogs obviously not gonna play the video
and uh
and there's apparently someone in it
they'll look like they're in a car and
they're just filming it the entire they
sit there filming it for like minutes
while this man is killed
nobody you can hear some people shouting
at the dogs no one attempts to intervene
nobody this is a neighborhood there are
people all around they're in the houses
no one does anything
to help this man instead they film it
now you can make an argument for filming
maybe you can make an argument for
filming uh horrific events
when it's a when a person is committing
a crime and then you could argue well I
want to film it so that we could capture
this person after the fact that at all
we have the evidence okay
but even in that case your first
priority and your first responsibility
as a human being is to help someone if
you can not to think about well uh you
know after this person is murdered then
we'll have video of it at least
but at least yeah the video comes in
handy there in this case what what do
you need the video for at all why does
this video need to exist I I mean I'm
not being glib about it but it's you
know there's not going to be any
question about what happened to this man
uh we don't need to check the video to
see that he was Malta death by dogs it's
incredibly obvious to everyone so you
don't need that what do you need the
video for why does this have to be on
video and then why does it have to be on
social media
I I just can't imagine you you're what
you see an elderly man being mold to
death and your reaction is to pull out
of to get it on video for what
um
now we could talk about the laws against
pit bulls which I of which I think there
should be
but we need to start
passing laws and enforcing laws that are
already in the books uh to hold people
accountable when they are bystanders and
make no attempt
you know a bystander is just sitting
there filming while someone is being
beaten murdered like when you start
holding people accountable for that
this this is not
it's just it's not it's uh it's
sub-human behavior is what we're all
becoming we're so I think we're so
desensitized to everything because we
see all the stuff on social media and
it's like the when you when you
encounter in real life you immediately
pull your phone out and then start
experiencing this real thing through
your phone as if you're kind of removed
from it but you're not you're right
there you're a person that's a person
they need your help help them
now
I know we can only go so far in blaming
people for not acting heroically there's
a reason why we call it heroism is that
it's it's above and beyond what you
would normally expect and so if we start
expecting everyone to be heroes then
we're not really and it's not heroism
anymore if it's expected
um
and so I understand so there's a certain
line there you know nobody knows what
they would do in a certain situation
like are you going to put yourself In
Harm's Way to help a stranger hopefully
you would but that does require heroism
maybe you start you know then you start
thinking about your own family and your
kids you want to make it back to them
and I understand you think about all
those things but
um
so maybe we don't expect bystanders to
be superheroes but we do have to expect
them to be human beings
and I just find it hard to believe
nobody could do anything to try to help
like just throw get I don't know get
some bricks get rocks like throw stuff
at this the dogs do something get a baby
noise a baseball bat no one has anything
no net no one has a gun
maybe not but I mean this is Texas no
one has a gun really
known as a crowbar no one has anything
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]